[موسيقى]
اذهب إلى سياتل واشنطن، قال المنتج الخاص بي
إنها ستكون رائعة،
هذه متعة مذهلة، هذه هي بحيرة
يونيون، الطقس متجمد وأنا
أغلي مثل جراد البحر في حوض من
الماء الساخن، ما الذي يمكن أن يحدث خطأ،
هذا حقيقي  كابتن الصلصال يغسل الأشياء،
هناك هراء هذا هو اسمك واقفًا
على الأرض، موضع
Space Needle هو مجرد مواقف مثالية
مميزة من تلقاء نفسها،
أنا على جسر
لا يوجد مكان فيه
كل الأشياء الغريبة التي
قمت بها أعتقد أن هذا هو  في الأعلى،
لم يكن هناك
ماء خارج المطار
في حوض الاستحمام الساخن الخاص بنا المدعوم بالخشب في
منتصف الشتاء الرائع
[موسيقى]
تمنحني بحيرة Union نقطة مراقبة رائعة
يمكنني من خلالها توجيه نفسي،
فهي قريبة من المركز الجغرافي لـ
سياتل التي
يذكرني بها الجميع دائمًا هي أعلى يسار قمة
الولايات المتحدة
للتأكد من الشمال وبعض
المدن الكندية البارزة وهذا ما
يفسر سبب جفاف الطقس في الشتاء لمدة
دقيقة واحدة حيث تتساقط الثلوج هناك
بعد ذلك وليس هناك ما يمكنك فعله سوى
احتضان  عدم القدرة على التنبؤ
[موسيقى]